[Música]
aquí comienza a ellos hoy de france 24
cada 25 de julio se conmemora el día
internacional de la mujer afro latina
afro caribeña y de la diáspora esta
lucha afro feminista es un esfuerzo más
contra la discriminación por racismo y
por machismo la fecha se observa desde
1992 cuando mujeres afrodescendientes de
32 países latinos se reunieron en santo
domingo en república dominicana para
celebrar la identidad negra y su aporte
contra las violencias en este programa
queremos unirnos a la conmemoración
honrando ese activismo y el afro
feminismo
justamente para la conversación están en
ella soy ser herrera que es periodista
anti racista y maestrante en estudios
afrocolombianos y ailín pérez carrascal
militante del movimiento de mujeres
negras y barriales de cartagena y
magister en cooperación internacional
para el desarrollo gracias a ambas por
hacernos parte de la conmemoración y por
abrir el espacio para una discusión tan
importante para el feminismo y para la
lucha de derechos comienzo con ustedes
ser y pidiéndole más que nada una
explicación para la audiencia desde
donde se ubica la mujer afro latina cómo
se relacionan estos tres conceptos de
una idea de raza de una idea de género y
de esta llamada clase social cuando
hablamos de la lucha de la mujer afro
latina
muchas gracias por la invito invitación
angela bueno en primer lugar pues
explicar un poco acerca de el origen
histórico de la de lo que hace que las
mujeres de la diáspora lleguemos a
américa oa lo que llamaban antes en las
primeras naciones
había ayala esto tiene que ver con un
desarraigo con un con arrancar unos más
corporalidad es de áfrica y traerlas en
condición de esclavización a un nuevo
mundo que llamó euro
esto con un fin que mucha gente ya
conoce que es muy popular en relación a
como la gente lo percibe
la gente reconoce que existió la trata
que existió en la esclavización pero
muchas veces desconoce las implicaciones
que hoy en día este momento histórico
tiene sobre la vida de las poblaciones
afrodescendientes y de la diáspora en
todo el mundo no solamente en
latinoamérica
o en américa en general
entonces para explicar esto pues hay que
hablar de las implicaciones económicas
políticas sociales que tiene la idea de
la raza sobre la vida de las personas
marcadas racialmente como indígenas como
afrodescendientes como rooms en general
con todas las personas que no son
colocadas dentro del paradigma de lo
blanco entonces esas implicaciones
las han explicado de muchas maneras
diversas académicas
desde eeuu lo han explicado
patricia gil calling con la matriz de la
opresión esta matriz de la opresión
habla de que las mujeres son
oprimidos las mujeres negras en general
las mujeres racial izadas por la raza
por la clase y por el género entonces
las ideas y los constructos sociales
impuestos dt el patriarcado y la
gratitud
colocan sobre estos cuerpos unas
dimensiones
de opresión y unas condiciones un
estatus social por debajo de la
jerarquía en general de lo que
constituyó la colonización y esa matriz
de la opresión se explica desde todas
las dificultades que pueden tener las
personas que no están en la cúspide de
esta jerarquía creada por europa air
link de los datos del banco mundial dan
cuenta de una población de 133 millones
de personas afrodescendientes en américa
latina y el caribe esto fue un estudio
que se realizó en el 2018 y que sin
embargo ha sido criticado por las
comunidades racial izadas por contar con
muchos sesgos en los datos que entre
otras cosas no han permitido entender a
profundidad cuál es la situación de la
mujer afrodescendiente en nuestro
continente en las américas en el caribe
sabemos que las poblaciones negras
tienen una historia de vulnerabilidad
que ha sido impuesta pero más allá de
eso el link como debe ser el trabajo
para elevar a la figura de la mujer
negra
bueno muchas gracias por la invitación
por colocar en el centro las
experiencias la piel la voz y el cuerpo
de las mujeres negras creo que estoy al
comienzo también una etapa de los
caminos que los movimientos sociales las
mujeres organizada hemos venido siendo
entonces yo me sitúo en cartagena de
indias
está en el caribe colombiano
pensado como un puerto de y pues ese
pensamiento y esa construcción de
cartagena compuesto a negri no se trata
de la vista todavía sigue viendo desde
el genocidio estadístico que está
configurado desde el tan indicar en
colombia con el departamento nacional de
estadísticas y luego escala a nivel
internacional con datos que genera el
banco mundial y otras entidades
transnacionales
permite identificar que existe un
racismo estructural es decir el género
se inventarió con la población
afrodescendiente e impide entender
realmente cuáles son las condiciones
típicas mujeres negras en que el país en
el mundo es equivalente a una huella
color y a decirle un tema aislado que
está configurado y recreado producido
para servir a un sistema que aún
perpetua hechos de la conciencia que se
existe pero yo considero que estas
reflexiones del que se debe hacer
nuestras abuelas las pensaron en la
dieta colombiana a ella de nuestras
abuelas en nuestra tiza web y la misma
desde déjese de texas ganas y de se
inventó un negro extraño de liberación
ellas mismas crearon y diseñaron caminos
de libertad caminos que hoy las mujeres
negras jóvenes estamos tratando de
tratar desde que forma desde diferentes
perfiles de imaginarios hay que romper y
desde la fortaleza orca ins activa
social en otras por ejemplo sentimos la
necesidad de pensar nos lo organizativo
de base la configuración de las
comunidades negras
socialización durán castro un poco clara
y racista con un eje para poder cortar
esas cadenas de temple a virtud que
todavía estamos bien que yo considero
que no es pues en que ser esfuerzos
tanto por participar que no un colono
que debe de entender las opresiones que
está marcando se recuperó de la negra
sexualizadas comercializables parque
tablets y también desde las propias
comunidades negras las mujeres negras
viéndonos como una forma necesaria de
organizarnos y poder entender la
comunicación horizontal como una forma
de gustar camino de líderes bueno sé
quiero que es por parte y parte no el
que se sacude en que oprime y nosotros
estamos vigentes de nuestra propia forma
de entender que debemos de en cuestionar
nuestros puntos y buscar una forma
distinta
pierre yves de vista amoroso como lo
hice en el extravió presidenta francia
mano que además es la primera
vicepresidenta una mujer negra que
ejerce este cargo en colombia bien este
programa se nos pasa muy rápido así que
les tengo que pedir que vayamos siendo
breves en las siguientes respuestas para
que alcancemos más tema pero sobre estas
diferentes luchas que se adoptan para
rescatar y sobre todo para reivindicar
ese será afro ese venir de la diáspora
de ese venir de áfrica es un enfoque que
rescata una estética negra no es una
manera de dvd de ver esa realidad
ancestral y ver que la humanidad viene
de áfrica y por eso quisiera pedirle ser
que nos hablara sobre esa reivindicación
del pelo afro de la estética afro que es
hermosa pero que no ha sido respetada
bueno para mí el tema estético es
importante y es político definitivamente
para las mujeres negras no es
simplemente un tema superficial esta
identidad y estas maneras porque son muy
diversas de construirnos
físicamente y exponernos en el mundo
muchas veces son motivos de rechazo y la
posibilidad de llevar el cabello natural
no era tan sencilla hace algunos años y
que hoy nuestra vicepresidenta lleve el
cabello a fort es algo muy poderoso y
que deja un mensaje muy importante para
las niñas para las adolescentes y para
las mujeres en general
y esa relación de que nuestro cabello si
está bien hay muchísimas activistas que
han realizado trabajos muy importantes
para la reivindicación de la estética
afro no solamente del cabello sino
también de la ropa y es algo muy
poderoso que podemos ver en nuestra
actual vicepresidenta
pero una cosa más allá de la estética
que me parece importante resaltar es
como el cuerpo de la mujer negra en
general por su apariencia es foco de
múltiples violencias la posibilidad de
no poder ser accedido será aceptada en
un trabajo por tener el cabello así es
muy latente en colombia y en
latinoamérica en general en eeuu y se
han venido desarrollando algunas
iniciativas para proteger el derecho a
llevar el cabello en distintas maneras
que tienen que ver con la con
experiencia sobre los peinados y una
historia de libertad que se ha trazado a
través de estos peinados con nuestras
ancestras pero más allá de las estéticas
yo siento que el tema de la violencia
sobre los cuerpos de las mujeres me
parece importante por ejemplo pensarnos
como en una ciudad como cartagena
y niñas como lisandro son desaparecidas
es como estamos hablando muchas veces de
la estética y la estética es importante
pero hay unos problemas políticos muy
grandes
yo creo que haya erlin puede hablar un
poco más acerca de ese proceso porque ha
sido más cercana a todas las luchas que
se han dado para poder dar con el
paradero de la lista que indica que fue
desaparecida entonces pensamos en
esclavitud y en la trata como algo que
pasó hace doscientos trescientos años en
los años 1600 pero nuestras niñas están
siendo desaparecidas para la trata de
personas
actualmente en colombia entonces la
esclavitud es una esclavitud que no ha
desaparecido nuestras niñas siguen
siendo raptadas para ser esclavizadas
entonces me gustaría que pudiéramos
hablar un poco más acerca de esa lucha
que está llevando a alguien pérez en
este momento con el colectivo de el
movimiento de mujeres negras en
cartagena
bueno pues los espacios en televisión
son lamentablemente muy cortos y
solamente podemos llegar a la punta del
iceberg y haber las preguntas pues desde
el exterior ya nos quedamos sin tiempo
hay línea yo le diría que si usted
quiere muy rápidamente pero muy
rápidamente de su conclusión y para el
cierre las dos lo que les quiero pedir
es este ejercicio tan bello de como
ustedes se identifican una mujer una
académica una activista una mujer de la
diáspora
bueno yo me reconozco el autor reconozco
como una mujer negra una mujer negra
variant que nació y creció en la
periferia de cartagena y que hoy junto
con muchas mujeres en cartagena que
también te transversalizan con esa
identidad estamos luchando por restituir
nuestros derechos para decirle a la
gente nosotras somos humanas
requerimos que nos vean como tal y
requerimos que entiendan que conocemos
sus formas de opresión que conocemos
quiénes son conocemos sus nombres y cuál
es el juego que también la gente o
figuran en la ciudad que es turística y
ejerce diputación sexuales sobre las
mujeres les agradezco ayer por marca de
malick sangre y un tarro yo es una mujer
negra de la periferia de cartagena 16
años que pueden estar está desaparecida
de hace un año y cuatro meses y los
reconocemos como un trabajo
qué hacen desde la red de trata en
colombia y el internacional
en este villano de piano muchas gracias
a ustedes todos por sus puntos de vista
y sobre todo por su activismo gracias a
ustedes gracias a nuestros televidentes
por estar con nosotros sigan en france
[Música]